reproductive rights groups held bans off
our bodies rallies around the country
and here in the valley today this in
response to the leaked draft of a
supreme court opinion that would
overturn roe v wade madison kimbrough
attended one of these events at sunset
park today she joins us live in studio
tonight with the details
yeah these rallies come after a leaked
draft opinion that was signed by five
supreme court justices was released
publicly in the beginning of may in it
was the decision to overturn roe v wade
saturday a pro-choice rally was held at
sunset park hosted by planned parenthood
votes nevada several city and state
officials were in attendance along with
governor steve sisilak who spoke to the
crowd we are facing real world problems
when it comes to abortion and women's
health rights this was the second rally
hosted by planned parenthood the other
took place earlier in the month in front
of the federal courthouse downtown
organizer raquel cruz juarez says the
support they have seen is massive with
over 200 people showing up to saturday's
rally she also shares why this was so
vital for her to be a part of health
care shouldn't be politicized
unfortunately a husband people have to
share their story to humanize the issue
but if this affects everybody you know
i'm here as an immigrant and also as a
woman and also as the daughter of a
person that decided to have an abortion
many years ago right now abortion is
still legal up to 24 weeks across the
country here in nevada it's protected by
the state's constitution but for 26
other states come this summer it could
be banned i feel like i stepped into a
time machine and somebody threw me back
in history the decision that may come
down from the supreme court is going to
affect all of us down the road one way
or another but i do feel very strongly
that abortion is a women's right
abortion is health care
and as for a final decision by the
supreme court it's still unknown when
that will be but until the organizations
like planned parenthood tell us they
will continue to hold events like this
to make their message clear in the
studio madison kimbrough live local now